oh thank you Mr chairman good morning
and uh members of the committee good
morning as well I'm Senator David Waters
uh District Four to introduce some
Senate bill
uh 14 relative to the use of game
cameras
um I will very briefly uh present what
are the actual
um
parts of the legislation are as amended
by the the house and then talk a little
bit about some of the background of the
bill and then we have lots of folks here
from Fish and Game and Timberland
Association uh Owners Association and
others as well
um what this bill tries to get at is the
balancing of the use of game cameras and
uh privacy rights and so the work that
has been done in this in the Senate and
in the house I think we're into five or
six years working on this since the
technology has arisen and tried and
gotten kind of close in many bills and I
think we thought we gotta we got pretty
pretty good job done in the Senate I
think the Bill's been improved in the
houses as well
um so what you have here are some
definitions of what a game camera is and
a technology that's involved
um with it and uh then the provisions
about when they are able to be used for
hunting per minimum or fur bearing
animal
um how they
you can locate them use them and then
restrictions on house soon after they've
taken an image that they can go out and
do their their hunt which makes some
good sense there and then it turns to
the property owner rights and it talks
about
we've got any permission we went back
and forth a lot about how the commission
were given did anybody given so on and
so forth and uh so now we have the
language here about getting the
permission or someone can post their
land to say
that the use is permitted on these lands
um and uh then
as we have with tree stands and other
things there's a date by which they
ought to be removed every year uh unless
the owner has explicitly allowed it to
to stay on past the December 30 31st and
then since the game cameras are actually
the property of the person who places it
and the somebody who sees one and says I
don't want that camera in my tree and
you know takes it out there actually I'm
removing or damaging potentially
somebody's properties so that that's why
the procedure needs to be in here that
um that someone who's able to take that
camera down can be informed to come out
and take it out of the out of the woods
for the um a property owner and then you
see some Provisions here for uh use of
them in research and then for law
enforcement activities as as well
um so that's that's what the bill tries
to do but let me go back a little bit to
the kind of balancing of issues here uh
and you know
um as I I think back
representative Lynn to common law and
you know Robin Hood was pretty didn't
have Robin who didn't have game cameras
but he was sure concerned about Open
Access of of public lands and that is so
deeply rooted in common law in our
traditions in this state
um and so how do we balance out the
right of Rights of public access to land
with the rights of the property owners
uh uh to privacy and to regulate what
goes on on on their land now um you know
what makes this so such an important
issue is that we need to get this right
because as they are being used and as
the technology of course uh improves and
increases um people are concerned about
their privacy and if we don't
provide a system here that works for
private land owners they are going to
post their land just to no trespassing
and no hunting and for those of us you
know I was on fish and game when I was
in the house and I wanted to Natural
Resources if we're going to make sure
the hunting can continue in our state we
have to make sure that this this good
balance is there so that people will
keep their land open and you know the
worst result would be for large
landowners particularly coming in from
out of state buying large amounts of
land and not familiar with the culture
of Open Access and hunting will just by
default post all their property there's
some of that going on so this is why you
know land owners Timberland Owners
Association Fish and Game have worked so
hard over many years now and why they
asked me to bring this bill forward in
the in the Senate so um very glad to
answer some questions but we have a lot
of people who also want to talk about as
any questions for Senator Waters
Senator Waters someone asked
oh thank you Mr chairman
um thank you for your testimony Senator
Waters um I just have a question about
section one
um and it the the requirement that no
person shall take the game animal a fur
bearing animal within the same calendar
day of remotely viewing that that image
how is there how does how is that
enforced or how
what's the expectation for I mean I get
the rationale for it but how would you
ensure that that doesn't happen well I'm
going to let the official game folks um
just speak to that but there is some
enforcement around around that and um
you know that's that's something that we
that you know has has been has been a
concern and uh questions of fair hunt
um and I think that I I again I'm gonna
let fishing game but I do believe we
have some Provisions that are similar to
this relating to the issue of baiting as
well so
um I'll let them speak to that okay
thank you enforcement side
and representative Murphy just based on
my knowledge the
the camera will actually put a date time
stamp when it sends a picture as well as
the cell phone itself will show when it
came in so it is absolutely provable
when it was sent to when it was received
and if they happen to be there when you
harvest it they can put it together it's
a matter of some math and looking at the
two devices but I'm sure they'll expound
in that way thank you Mr chairman yeah
uh with that the chair recognizes
um
good morning
and thank you for the opportunity to
speak on behalf of the Senate Bill 14.
Mark and I are the owners of 500 Acres
next to the guile State Forest our land
is not posted
we have been named the New Hampshire
Tree Farm of the year for 2022 in
recognition of our
significant wildlife habitat management
we've had five moose taken on the
property since 2004.
we facilitate Hunters on our property we
have allowed game cameras to be used in
two instances with written permission
and we knew exactly where the cameras
were
of but we do not want to have people
come onto our property without
permission and Place game cameras or
tree stands for that matter on our
property without knowing where they are
we have 10 miles of trails that are
managed and are
used frequently by the public
and we feel that it would be an invasion
of our privacy and of the other folks
who use our land
if a game camera were set up anywhere
near these trails
um our other concern is that we actively
manage our property we've had four
Timber harvests since 2004 we are
planning a Timber Harvest this year or
next year that's always dependent on
ground conditions and uh so if there
were game cameras on the property or
tree stands on the property and we
didn't know where they were then they
could be taken down with the timber
Harvest or damaged and we would prefer
not to have that happen to the owners of
that equipment
welcome any questions but we know we're
supposed to keep our comments short so
um while I appreciate pithiness if
there's anything else you want to add go
ahead I I just had one real quick thing
I we retired to New Hampshire
20 years ago or so
and one of the reasons we did one of the
big reasons we did is because we were so
pleased that we could meet in a
situation like this we're came from
Chicago where you had to put a hundred
dollars on the table just to get the to
talk to you to talk to your Alderman so
that's that's our whole year's salary
yes we know that we know that but I I
just want to say that it and I and I I
don't want to get too excited but it's
my land my land and zland and one of the
nice things about New Hampshire is your
land is your land
and it isn't belong to somebody else and
you can't be told
without the common law I heard the word
common law which is true and good but
it's my land yeah
um we we love having people uh use our
property including Hunters we've had uh
a wonderful relationships with the
hunters who have used our property they
we have found them to be knowledgeable
respectful
um and that's probably 99
of the folks who come on to our land one
of the reasons that we bought the land
next to the guile State Forest
was to
enhance uh the opportunities for the
public to use this land in perpetuity
and we have taken the expense and the
steps to place the conservation easement
on the property
to ensure that it will not become a
Walmart parking lot or a Housing
Development
and it is we're prejudiced but we think
it's a beautiful piece of land
and one of the other things that we've
done we know that our management has
benefited while life but this year
through 2026 we have hired Wildlife
biologists to survey the animals and
plants on the property uh
before a Timber Harvest and then after a
Timber Harvest to determine whether in
fact our Timber management is beneficial
to the plant and animal species on the
land so we're serious about
providing this as a public resource and
documenting it and sharing that
information
with others who might find it beneficial
but we do feel strongly about
knowing if people have game cameras on
um for your testimony and your sharing
of your property if I may ask if these
two bills pass is it your intention to
continue on allowing your property to be
shared in the way that you have
um our our conservation easement
requires that the land
be continued to be open to hunting
however we will put up signs that say uh
permission written permission is
required for tree stands and game
cameras
that would be within the provisions of
our conservation easement
uh any further questions to these
Witnesses
thank you very much for your testimony
appointed chair will recognizes Sheila
thank you for letting me speak I'm
Sheila Thompson and this is my husband
Tom
I'm here to ask you to pass game camera
build Senate bill 14.
I own several Parcels of land in Orford
in Wentworth New Hampshire during good
weather I'm often out on the properties
for several hours hiking around with
either a friend or my family and that
might include my granddaughter and
grandson
one of the issues that I would like to
raise is that I don't want to worry
about where there might be a camera when
I or one of my grandchildren or friends
needs to take a bathroom break
that's not a time when we should have to
worry about where the cameras are
located
please think about my privacy
I own the property
the landowner needs to be asked so that
we know where any cameras are located
please pass this bill
thank you for having both Sheila and
myself here to testify on this bill
actually the letter that I presented has
both bills in it so I'd like to share
that letter with you and read it into
the minutes
Mr chairman and committee members my
name is Tom Thompson owner of the
Thompson family tree farm with my wife
Sheila
we own two thousand four hundred acres
in Orford and Wentworth and manage it as
a sustainable Forest I have owned Forest
land for over 66 years and have been a
advocate for several for many years of
opening and sharing our forest land with
both the state of New Hampshire and the
General Public
we have over 12 miles of wood roads and
skid trails that we allow the snowmobile
clubs to use
we open our land for many other
activities for foot traffic such as
hunting hiking
photography birding annual butterfly
counts snowshoeing cross-country skiing
along with many tours that we give each
year
I support Senate bill 14 relative to the
U.S use of game cameras and Senate Bill
15 relative to the use of tree stands
and observation blinds as written in
these bills and recently both bills were
passed by the Full House and Senate
this is a privacy issue for our family
as a forest landowner and tree farmer I
can tell you many other tree Farmers
throughout New Hampshire feel the same
as we do
we have many special spots on our
property that we have family gatherings
or tours and last thing we need to worry
about is someone that has placed a
camera without permission and has the
latest technology and plays it back
in real time on a cell phone which can
be put on social media within minutes
we as landowners should not have to
worry about what we are doing and saying
on our own property
I watched the latest video of the
hearing on April 4th on these two Senate
bills in fish and game and Marine
resource committee
and was shocked when I heard a member of
this committee say and I'm paraphrasing
that no landowner should have the
expectations of privacy on his land
it's this kind of statement from a
public official that will drive private
landowners to post their lands
as a landowner who has purchased my
first woodlot 125 Acres when I was six
years when I was 11 years old
and for the last 66 years I have shared
that woodlot and many other wood Lots
over the years I have enjoyed the many
folks who have given us the courtesy of
asking permission to hunt Place game
cameras and Dr Sands on our property and
we also appreciate the many calls and
cards Thanking us for sharing our lands
it's this kind of attitude that will
keep New Hampshire private lands open
as of today I have testified four times
this year just in support of these bills
as written and passed by the Senate and
recently by the full house but for some
reason it has been referred to criminal
justice and Public Safety Committee
please pass the bills as they were
passed by the Full House
in these Bill if these bills fail to
pass and do not become law to protect
the privacy of our private lands our
2400 Acres will be posted for the first
time in 66 years
I can assure you many more thousands of
acres in New Hampshire will also be
posted because the New Hampshire
legislature ignored the Privacy rights
of our New Hampshire landowners
who in the past have been willing to
share our lands with the general public
in the state of New Hampshire
thank you for your time and
consideration on this important issue
for all New Hampshire private Forest
landowners who own 72 percent of the 4.7
million Acres of forest land in New
Hampshire
one other thing I would like to add is
the New Hampshire major landowner
organizations New Hampshire Timberlands
New Hampshire Farm Bureau Society for
the protection of New Hampshire Farmers
which I'm all we are members of are here
today to support both bills thank you
I'm happy to answer any questions Mr
chairman thank you uh for your testimony
just for clarification it was referred
to this committee because it does
provide a penalty and anytime a bill
provides a penalty by law the criminal
justice committee hears it because it's
a criminal justice issue that's the only
reason that it was referred to this
committee does anyone else have any
questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
and at this point the chair recognizes
Susan price of New Hampshire Fish and
Game
thank you
my name is
Susan price I'm the Carroll County Fish
and Game commissioner and I'm also chair
of the legislative committee for the
commission
thank you chairman Roy and members of
the committee
listening and taking this bill very
seriously I normally come and sort of
wing it so to speak
but this is a not only a very important
issue for
um the landowners who have spoken but
Fish and Game the commission uh
providing Public Access is actually one
of our duties charged to us under RSA
2064a
and the key to both the creation of the
commission is that we are the citizen
Representatives
and under item three one of our duties
is to ensure public access to private
land
for recreational use
it's not for hunting use it's not for
fishing use trapping it's for all
recreational use so we want to stress
that this is not just about hunters
using Game consists to public land for I
mean private land for the public
um
so we take this so seriously that we
actually have a program at the
department that is dedicated to
landowner relations we provide signs we
provide Personnel to go out to talk to
people that have large tracts of land I
per Commissioners reach out I've done
this uh recently in Carroll County where
we had some people such as the senator
spoke of that moved in and immediately
posted 200 acres of land that had never
been posted in in the town before and we
were able I was able to speak with them
and get it unposted so we take this the
these relationships with the private
landowner very seriously at Fish and
Game
um I don't believe anyone has spoken of
the percentage of private land in the
state but it's at the 76 percent level
so for us to provide Public Access
maintaining these landowner
relationships and respecting private
property rights are very important and
this does bring in the constitutional
right under article 2B of the New
Hampshire Constitution to a right to
privacy nowhere in our constitution is a
guaranteed of public access to private
land to which you have no legal standing
to be on this is about the generosity of
private landowners you've heard prior
testimony from two couples
and we just have worked very hard on
this bill the last several years with
the stakeholders and we feel like we've
gotten it right this time and we would
very much appreciate criminal Justice's
support and this can move to the
governor's desk I'll be glad to take any
yeah I just have one question on section
four Roman numeral four of the proposed
bill it says a property owner shall
contact us uh a local or state law
enforcement officer conservation officer
to remove
and sees a game camera which was placed
in violation of this section is it you
are understanding that that means that's
what you have to do in other words if I
own land
and somebody has without my permission
posted a game camera
do I have to call Fish and Game or can I
just go out and take the camera down
I'm I'm going to defer to the colonel
when he comes up because he deals with
us and the officers deal with this all
the time and Senator Waters spoke to
this in his initial testimony some of
these game cams are attached to trees
with cables so there is an issue of
damaging someone's property that's been
placed on your property and so to create
to minimize that conflict most
landowners will currently call the
department for assistance but I'll defer
to the kernel in more pragmatic matters
with that situation thanks
any further questions
this time the chair recognizes Jeff
Eames
or fames I can't
well good morning
for the record my name is Jeff Eames I'm
a resident of Epsom New Hampshire I grew
up in Deerfield New Hampshire
we own a business uh called Fort
Mountain Land and Timber Fort Mountain
Trucking and our business is primarily
Forest management harvesting Timber Road
building working with landowners across
the state of New Hampshire
we manage about we work with landowners
about 30 000 Acres right around here
some of our clients include Pembroke
Water Works
Manchester Water Works the Whittemore
family
uh the Mathis family in Deerfield
and myself and my wife own a thousand
acres of land in Epson Allenstown and
Deerfield
I encourage you to visit our website if
you have a chance it's called new
hampshireforestry.com and give you a
real good idea of what and how we do
things
I'm here to ask the committee to pass
the bill as a House and Senate who
written it and why
I'm in forestry business every day we
have employees which is 13 Going to the
woods except for the truck drivers
every day we find a different camera a
different tree stand
and
we got to remove those we just can't
work in an environment with tree stands
and cameras
and we somewhat feel of a certain
responsibility to contact that person
who owns it to give it to them
the landowner assistance program has
done things like taking pictures of
cameras and put them on Facebook to find
a rightful owner and it becomes a horror
show
all the dialogue that goes on with that
Facebook stuff whether it's login
whether it's
you know changing of the land
it's not fun and all we'd like to do is
return that product to its rightful
owner
state of Michigan concludes that 47
percent of hunters today use game
cameras you take that factor and put it
in New Hampshire
that's over 50 000 cameras out there
every day like I said myself in the
forestry team are in the woods making
decisions helping landowners manage
their property
yeah I got involved with this business
40 years ago
since then the clients that we have have
changed
their property is not just a wood lot
anymore they take a lot of Pride and
ownership they practice all kinds of
different diverse management whether
it's Wildlife Management whether it's
water quality whether it's forestry
whether it's Recreation and we've
adapted the change with them but however
it's not just the woodlot anymore it's
someone's personal property and I can
tell you that they get very offended
when they find game cameras and tree
stands on their property
and one of the first things that they do
um
dealing with game cameras it's a problem
personally
I've been threatened
okay I'm on a job someone shows up and
said hey you took my tree stand you took
my camera I didn't take it
yeah you better watch your back Eames
your equipment's gonna burn
what
this morning I met with Scott Ralph he's
a Forester managing land for the State
of New Hampshire the regional manager
and I said what do you think about this
oh man he says you know how much time I
spend on trying to find the owners of
these things
I guess as a taxpayer do I really want
someone interrupting his daily
activities to go find the owner of
treason tree stands and game cameras
they are known as like Manchester
Waterworks are so frustrated with it
that they have come up with their own
policy and I encourage you if I can
leave this with you
it is
hunting permit required they own about 8
000 Acres right around Manchester New
Hampshire
that's a big land base for recreational
for our biggest component of Manchester
and vicinity
they're so frustrated with it that they
came up with their own policy regarding
tree stands nothing to do with game
cameras
so I'd like to introduce this I only
brought one copy
um for the board for their committee to
review
and I guess with that in mind
I feel a lot more comfortable when being
in the woods and I do in this committee
if you have any questions I'm happy to
go ahead and representative renewal
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in and talking to us today I just
wanted to ask really quickly especially
um in the event that someone is trying
to return the property
um the landowner finds something and
wants to return it this bill provides
for obviously having the information
providing for permission and things like
that is it your contention that as the
representative mentioned before that
having
um uh fishing games so contacting a
local or state law enforcement officer
or conference conservation officer would
reduce the risk of having that
interaction like you were describing
where it was contentious and and um
trouble between the landowner and the
owner of the property
yeah absolutely if there was some chain
of custody to what that was going on out
there it would eliminate the negative
activity or actions of the
tristanona or the game camera
and Mr chairman can I give this deal Yes
actually if you on the way out if you
could hand it to our assistant she'll
make copies for the whole committee
at this point the chair recognizes
I discovered in the last few months I
have a real hearing problem
in a situation like this so thank you
for your patience
uh I am Walter Lacy
from keen and my wife and I own 650
acres of land in Keene Swansea and
Chesterfield
although not a hunter myself I believe
very strongly in con traditional uses of
the land and hunting is certainly one of
them
our land has always been open to hunting
and trapping I can't imagine that
changing that being said said I've had a
problem with tree stands over the years
twice with Associated game cameras
in two instances healthy valuable oak
trees were damaged
none of the stands or camera said
contact information on them and all my
efforts to communicate with the owners
by leaving my contact information on
flagging tape was unsuccessful
in the most recent incident because of
the nature of the camera involved a fish
and game officer was able to identify
the offender
the mutual benefits of having contact
information on this equipment seem
undeniable
a simple phone call could clear up any
question a landowner might have and 100
might get back a misplaced stand or
camera
the increasing use and sophistication of
game cameras should require permission
for the use on private land
the idea that something is allowed in my
backyard
but not yours is unacceptable
it all seems to me a matter of common
courtesy
if you want to leave a piece of gear on
someone else's land you get permission
put your name on it
what could be simpler than that
I don't like to see land posted I think
it's a short-sighted measure
if the common sense requirements of SB
14 and 15 are not enacted however
I'm afraid land owners may be left with
no other choice
with privileges come some
responsibilities
and I have to add one of the greatest
rewards of owning land is being able to
share it
so I hope we can
get these issues cleared up thank you
any questions for the win sorry
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee
I submitted um by email a letter
to the chair on I guess it was Sunday
evening May 14th
so that that letter I'll just kind of
read a few things from it
but record I'm Mark ledgard I've lived
here in New Hampshire nearly all my life
hunted here all my life since my father
gave me a BB gun to start hunting with
um I'm certified New Hampshire Fish and
Game Hunter Safety instructor
I'm representing myself as a private
landowner I own 40 acres I had some land
up in Northern New Hampshire just
recently sold that camp as a hunting
camp
I also participate in Hunter mentoring
program I've hunted
people of all ages men and women
recently in
1981 year old Hunter last year for a
first year
and I got him out there he got his first
deer never been hunting his entire life
he also got a 21 pound turkey better
than I have ever gotten
um I've been in 35 years Environmental
Compliance I'm now retired but I work
part-time for the town of Sanbornton New
Hampshire whereas I live I'm doing land
use planning and regulation zoning
enforcement officer
my wife and I right now we own 40 acres
in San Bernard New Hampshire we have it
open to people to hunt
um
people hiking whatever they want to do
snowshoeing horse horseback riding we
enjoy people utilizing Our Land
I did have to put up some no hunting
without permission because some people
went out there and were hunting left
trash and did some damage to my land so
I don't have anything against anybody
hunting
um because I'm an avid Hunter myself I
just want to make sure that when people
are on my land I know what they're doing
um so I don't see this bill I agree with
the Senate bill 14 and 15. I see it
actually as protecting our hunting
Heritage because it's putting the
landowner private land owner
having some say in what they do which is
basically what we want to do
um and it's going to preserve a hunting
Heritage I've seen a lot of land being
posted as other people have testified
today and here I am trying to Mentor
some young Hunters older hunters and and
the land is getting posted I'm having a
hard time finding places for them to go
to and Hunt where you know they can feel
comfortable out there so I think
um and I do talk to land owners when I
go to hunt on their property I generally
don't put tree stands out there or
cameras but I do on my own property but
I ask for permission to hunt even if
it's not posted
so my wife and I both support these
bills as written
and with that most of that other
information is in this letter I'll open
see none um thank you for your testimony
good morning my name is AJ Hunter I'm
here representing myself I live in
Conway New Hampshire thank you for
letting me speak on this issue I
um I'm ignorant to a lot of the stuff
that's going on here and I'll admit that
um also kind of biased as a non-land
owner I'm very grateful to the common
law that we have and to the private
landowners that do allow us to access
their land I hunt predominantly on
public I do intermix with private that
is not posted and private that is posted
I utilize game cameras on public land
and the public that is not posted
um
what I see here is the first step to
restrict recreational use of tools on
private land
again a game camera is used for hunting
trapping all that stuff I know
photographers who use them to capture
pictures of wildlife there were
amendments that were introduced to 300
foot buffer zone around a dwelling or a
building that was taken out in a
previous committee that would have been
reasonable to put in there the other
thing that I see when it comes to large
tracks of landowner is something that
hasn't been brought up here it's the 20
recreational discount on current use
property tax when I see that I see a
financial and an economic thing again
I'm ignorant to stuff so I ask questions
about these things
um I do think that it does need to be
addressed I think that especially with
the live action cameras where we can see
stuff there that that's it's absurd
there is a right to privacy that people
should have I do question though that
right to privacy is that still there
when the land is open to the public for
recreational use
and posting the property would be making
it not open and would really codify that
that right to privacy I don't believe
that we should be encouraging people to
post I just see these types of things
asking questions hoping that you all can
maybe
pump the brakes on this this year have a
little bit more deliberation discussion
on what we can do to actually ensure a
healthy benefit on both sides thank you
any questions to the witness
a chair recognizes representative Judy
Aaron
thank you Mr chair and thank you members
of the criminal justice committee I'll
be brief because previous speakers have
pretty much touched upon a lot of what I
was going to say
but I I'm here today to support SB 14.
um
many of my constituents have contacted
me and asked me to come and support this
bill
I do support this bill I support hunting
I support property rights as well
being able to access private land is a
privilege
and as a courtesy we should ask the
owner permission to place cameras on
private land
we have to respect property rights
and bottom line these game cameras their
surveillance its surveillance on private
property
and again
you know if it's your land you don't
want to be walking out on your property
somewhere and doing something and be
I agree that um
we want to provide public access to
private land
but again we have to respect
that hunting and access to the private
land is a privilege
and that property rights and privacy are
more important
chair recognizes Robert Johnson
foreign
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Rob Johnson
representing the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau is the federation's policy
director here in support of Senate bill
14.
I have provided you with a handout this
morning
let our testimony
and I just would like to point out out
of that letter and stress that
any camera placed on private property
without the landowner's knowledge of it
being placed with a knowledge of who
placed it makes it in effect a
surveillance device and we believe it is
that simple
and in closing I just would like to add
and many of our
the landowners here who are our Farm
Bureau members as well have said it said
it very well that that in our membership
in general does takes great pride in in
keeping our land open and I know
personally for my family's land is
nothing better when you're out in the
yard you're working and somebody stops
by and thanks you for the for you know a
walk they took or or Wildlife they saw
and and that's that is uh
um it's very important uh to I think to
most landowners to to be able to share
their their their land
um
but in the end it is a courtesy that a
landowner should have the ability that
if they do not want a camera up on a
spot or a place or a time that they
should have the ability to say no and Mr
chair and more specifics to what this
committee is looking at the fine
schedule I just wanted to say that we
did work on this the bill with uh
fishing game and and I'll let the
colonel speak to that you know
specifically but to their
um it is something that we we uh we do
we do strongly support the bill and asks
Vita recommend it is ought to pass and
I'll leave it at that thank you
any questions for this Witness
chair recognizes
good morning thank you Mr chairman I'm
Matt Leahy I'm the public policy
director for the society for the
protection of New Hampshire Forest we
support the bill for really the reasons
you've already heard so I won't repeat
those I did just want to briefly mention
our interest in this issue and also just
make one additional point so the four
Society we are a private non-profit land
trust and Forestry organizations so we
own and protect land and and as part of
our
ownership and management we do conduct
Forest management you know Timber
Harvest on these lands we own so
um you know we do view ourselves as part
of the network of private landlords in
in our state and I just make one point
um about the reason we support the bill
you know we do view it you know we view
one of the benefits one of the key
benefits is that it will we think lead
to more and improved interactions
between private landowners and you know
those people who who are using their
lands and not just for uh for hunting
but you know hiking bird watching all
that
um and we think that's really important
um you know again as you've heard
um
you know the
you know maintaining these traditional
uses of our land is very important
that's why you know that's one of the
reasons why we do protect land so again
we think
you know improving those relationships
and interactions between landowners and
and the people who use their land is is
very important so again we support the
bill
have to answer any questions are there
any questions for the witness
the chair recognizes Karsten Springs is
okay
foreign
good morning my name is Kyle Baker and
I'm here on behalf of the New Hampshire
Wildlife Federation New Hampshire
Wildlife Federation is a Statewide
non-profit that represents approximately
50 Fish and Game clubs and associations
made up of the Trappers Association the
bear hunters Association
and approximately an affiliate
affiliated membership of about 50 000
Hunters Anglers and Trappers from around
the state
we're here to fully support Senate Bill
14. we think that this bill threads the
needle in preserving the Open Access to
lands but allowing and respecting the
private landowners in their willingness
to continue to allow for hunting and
fishing to happen on their land
we've been working with both Farm Farm
Bureau the Timberland owners fish and
game department for a number of years
now on legislation that we think uh will
address the problem as well as continue
to allow and Foster an active Sporting
Community in New Hampshire game cameras
are in as you heard are becoming
increasingly popular it wasn't long ago
that a game camera was you know 200 now
they're twenty dollars and they send the
pictures directly to your phone so
they're becoming more popular they're
also an incredible tool when it comes to
recruiting new Hunters there's nothing
that gets a kid more excited than
showing them a picture of a bear or a
deer that you know passed through the
woods behind their house the night
before and it could you know can really
help bring people into the sport as well
but that said there is a privacy concern
and we need to respect the folks that
allow us to hunt on their lands so we're
here to support I'm happy to answer any
questions but I wanted to be brief and
respect your time this morning
representative Bolden
I'm sorry if this has already been
covered maybe I missed it but two game
cameras transmit sound
um they do there are some that have the
ability to transmit sound which is a
whole nother level of um of concern and
privacy um but primarily
um the average game camera uh that you
know when I saw talk about a 20 game
camera
um they're primarily transmitting
pictures
um and
Silent Video but there are some that
have the ability to transmit
thank you and representative Bolden from
my understanding the um they can record
video and sound and keep it on a card on
the camera but for the most part what's
sent is just the pictures because of the
memory and data required thank you for
[Music]
well good morning for the record my name
is Jason stock I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Timberland
Owners Association and I want to thank
you for the opportunity to speak in
support of both
14 and 15. I'll
by way of background we our membership
totals around 1200 1300 members they're
Timberland owners uh as well as Forest
Products businesses and Industry
um
our Members Own or manage about a
million acres in the state of New
Hampshire
New Hampshire has a
as you heard earlier unlike some of the
western states a lot of the land in
particularly in the East but New
Hampshire especially about 76 percent of
it is is privately owned and we have a
great tradition of of what we call Open
Access people being allowed to enter
enter private property to recreate
and and use use that and that has really
spawned a very robust outdoor recreation
industry in New Hampshire
um to the tune of over a billion dollars
a year of economic activity and this is
everything from snowmobiling hiking
nature observation Hunting Fishing and
you know for us when we look at you know
those are traditional land uses you
heard current use mentioned earlier and
in fact current use actually provides an
incentive to land a further incentive to
landowners to maintain their property
open
and it's the the statute RSA 79a A4 is
is pretty specific it's it's skiing
snowshoeing fishing hunting hiking or
nature observation these are the those
are the you maintain your property open
12 months of the year
um that is in the current youth statute
as a landowner you can receive an
additional 20
reduction on your tax assessment and
that was quite intentional
um it was intentional to Foster and
encourage landowners to maintain open
um as you heard earlier cameras the the
game cameras
um the prices have come down they are
the technology has advanced
um and many landowners feel that they
are truly an invasion of their privacy
you've I won't reiterate what you've
heard earlier and for us we feel Senate
bill 14 does a good job at is is the
prior speaker said it threading that
needle not prohibiting the use of game
cameras we're not saying no game cameras
nowhere know how don't use them but
we're saying look
give us the courtesy
get the land ask the landowner for
permission to put them up and put your
name and contact information on them
people own land for a host of reasons
um and you know the idea or the notion
that well let's just limit this to 300
feet within a dwelling or within a
driveway that does not cover that family
picnic area that may be up on the back
side of a mountain
um that that does not that does not
include a perhaps a family family burial
plot down you know on the back side of
the back side of the meadow that's more
than 300 feet away and for landowners
these are special places and they don't
want to feel as if that area would could
get invaded private the privacy in that
area could get invaded with the camera
and so we feel that Senate bill 14
the permission and the labeling are
really common courtesy we think they're
they're great tools we have members that
use them many of our members I would
dare say the vast majority of our
members do open their open their land
for for hunting I am a hunter
um and I get a I get a real charge when
people hunt on my property youth turkey
weekend father and his son came up they
were new to the area asked me about
turkey hunting I showed them I I gave
them pretty good directions on where
I've seen a couple times earlier and
said go go for it go you know this is
great and so I think this bill really
does a good job at threading that needle
is is Kyle said and I think in the end
we'll maintain a better relationship
between Hunters The Hunting Community
and and landowners out there
um the the Senate Bill 15 likewise put
your name and contact information
we just want to know who to contact
UM as I've testified earlier you go into
a logging garage or a forester's office
in November and it's like a hunter's
pick and save because many times there's
cameras or there's tree stands that that
they have encountered or
you know that that they have to remove
or that fell off the tree whatever and
it's in the corner and they said I don't
even know who to contact
um so again I think just labeling them
in on this on the cameras in particular
getting that permission is is key
um with that I'll I'll conclude my
testimony I'd be happy to try to answer
any questions and I I thank you for your
thank you I have a question regarding do
you have
um any members that own large tracts of
land that are out of state that um in
other words I guess what I'm getting at
is I've heard some concerns from the
hunting communities like how would I get
in touch with someone that's kind of
like absentee if you will where do I go
to get permission as a yeah great
question
um well and there's it's actually become
very easy to contact landowners
um Onyx anyone that hunts knows there
are programs out there that can that can
identify who the who the owner is
um in fact that young man and his son
came up and pulled his map up and said
okay where is that where is your hay
field that you said that we could go in
and I could Point him right to it
there's that the other piece is that
many and if there is an out-of-state
landowner if if property's owned by a
trust or it's owned by someone who lives
out of state they they almost all have a
local manager they almost all have
someone like you heard earlier like a Mr
Eames or another local manager and it's
it's relatively easy to identify those
if they've done a Timber sale in recent
history there's a whole you have Timber
tax records all of that where people are
filing documents at the town office it's
open for public disclosure that says
who's the who's the quote land manager
for that out of state
um and so there are ways to ways to
identify it it's not impossible Onyx
would be your first go-to place tax
records are another and
um of course asking around town in in
looking at you know trying to figure out
okay calling a local logger or calling a
local Forester
who owns the peace on
you know Bear Mountain Road oh yeah
that's owned by such and such that's
actually uh I may not I may be mistaken
but I think I have that app Onyx on my
phone right now it's an awesome app well
primarily because it shows you the
distance from distance from uh
residences if you where you were going
to fire a weapon or something make sure
you're not within that that footage
um so
that app would show me then who who owns
that property is that I I that app I've
I've spoken to some Foresters and other
other Hunters um Onyx is one there are
other apps out there that and of course
you go to a town website many of these
towns have tax records right there
electronically I've had I've had folks
on their phone go to a town go to a town
website and pull up the pull up the app
um again on the Onyx one I don't have
that on my phone this fellow had it on
on his phone
um and he was walking me through it and
it appeared to have had my name on it on
my parcel so thank you any further
questions for the witness
uh representative Mr chair you could
rule this question out of order but I
can't help but ask why do people shoot
turkeys you can't eat them
actually I I would answer that by
telling you that the breasts are quite
delicious
um feel free to expound
I can give you some recipes
[Laughter]
yeah they do in springtime that they
hunt them in the fall and in the spring
and it's yeah this time of year month of
May
oh yeah at this point the chair
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for your time and your service
that hundred dollars reminds us every
now and then that that is uh really some
pretty good service that you provide for
us so I want to start the same way I
started every one of these hearings by
thanking these landowners behind me who
took time out of their day for a fourth
time to come down here and and I'd like
you to remember one very important fact
it was mentioned to me in the hallway
they're here to ask you to allow them to
to keep their land open I think that's
kind of interesting I can see it if they
came down to post it they're here in an
effort to keep it open for guys like me
who want to hunt so that we can hunt
later on and I think what they're asking
I don't think I firmly believe what
they're asking is reasonable and another
point I want to make and I know I'm
going to embarrass her and I I will ask
for forgiveness but Mrs Thompson has
never testified before and felt strongly
enough today to come down for the first
time so I commend her for doing that and
that's how important it is to these
landowners it is the number one
complaint excuse me that I get in the
fall is from landowners who find tree
stands and or cameras on their property
and they didn't have any knowledge that
they were placed there oh it didn't have
the opportunity to say yes or no to it
and so they asked me if people can
legally do that and I I just I don't we
don't ever lie to anyone and I said yes
they can by law and so the next actual
question is how do I prevent that well I
don't really want to answer that
question because the only way that they
can prevent it is to post their property
and I'm not in that business I work
pretty hard and my staff works pretty
hard to encourage people to try and
address the issues of why they posted
their property and get that property
opened
um and and you heard several landowners
behind me who are knowledgeable enough
from all four corners of the state by
the way we have landowners here from the
North Country we have landowners from
the southwest corner of the state and
the central part of the state so it's a
good representative representation of
our entire State and it's a good
representation of the landowners that I
speak with regularly and so I I don't
lie to them I tell them you can prevent
it by Pro posting your land and you
would lose your tax benefit if you were
taking advantage of that I can tell you
there are a lot of landowners that are
here today that really don't I don't
think that's a deciding factor I think
it's a mistake to think that that's
going to keep our land open because of
from experience I can tell you it
doesn't they get to a point where
they're tired of it and I would ask you
to think about this I'm a landowner I
pay eight thousand dollars a year in
taxes it's a lot of money
and my land is open and always will be
open under any circumstance for a whole
host of reasons but I would be very
angry if I went out my back door and
walked on my property and found a camera
and someone didn't have the courtesy to
just ask I would have allowed it a lot
of these landowners are not here I guess
I won't speak for these folks a lot of
landowners I speak with are not against
cameras they just want to know who it is
they want to know and there's certain
areas on their property that they don't
want a camera and you know the way I
look at that is I've got a small piece
nothing like Mr Thompson has nothing
like the acreage that he has but I have
a small piece that's very important to
me if someone were to park a car behind
my home or behind any of your homes you
would immediately call the police
well the landowner feels that way when
they find a camera that no one's asked
permission for it's on their property be
it 300 feet from their home or 3 000
feet that's their property they're
paying for that the taxes don't go down
the further we get away from a home
right they pay the same money so that
land is just as important to them on
that Back 40 as it is the front 40.
please remember that I think that's key
it's an issue really of of a landowner's
rights so so now I sit back taking these
calls
um and and I and I'm my other goal is to
protect the Sportsman that's really and
that my heart is in that because I'm a
sportsman so how do we balance these two
things and I think this bill has done a
really good job in doing that we got
together I got together with the
Wildlife Federation we got them on board
the sports men and women we got the Farm
Bureau on board we got the Timberlands
Association we all got together and said
there's got to be a way to do this so
that we not we're not punishing hunters
and we're recognizing the right of
landowners and this this bill was
written kind of with all of those
efforts in mind it's been changed I've
lost track of how many times it's
changed but I think what's in before you
today looking at it
um is is probably the best version so
it's one that I really I really would
encourage you to consider
um
I'm I want to make sure I've hit all my
but another thing that that is I never
thought of happening so if you follow
any of the deer hunting websites or or
not websites but that shows you what I
know about the internet Facebook pages
my my uh my younger officers do that and
they tell the old man how to how to look
at this stuff so I start doing it and I
was amazed when I see some of the some
Hunters have areas that they put their
stands and their cameras up and they go
back to this area year after year like I
do and they they you know they harvest
deer every year and it becomes their
area
and so you'll see pictures posted on
Facebook of a hunter standing or a
person standing in front of their camera
and they'll literally post on Facebook
and say who is this guy that's in my
area
on three occasions it's been the
landowner
now I don't have to tell you how how
quickly my phone rings when that happens
because now you've got a landowner whose
picture's on Facebook he's been insulted
by these people and he wants them off
their property I can't do a lot with
that quite frankly I can't honestly say
well you know that that wasn't you know
it just puts you in a really bad and I
don't think Hunters do it intentionally
I just don't think they think about that
and that happens to people so that's
that's another concern about I have fun
with them I stand in front of them I
hold cards up call me because I know it
takes the picture and Hunter's going to
see it I'm with these guys I never hear
from these folks of course we take them
on occasion when a landowner doesn't
want them there we'll remove them when I
get a very angry landowner because I
don't want him to post it so we'll
remove it and I I could put more
Sporting Goods out of business with the
equipment I have because nobody ever
claims it they don't they think they're
going to get a ticket and and so they
don't it's it's just a mess the way it
is and I think this is balances both
this is going to allow a hunter an
opportunity to go in and still put his
cameras up and it's going to respect the
rights of the landowner so you had a
couple of really good questions one is
how do we find the landowner
representative Roy the chairman brought
up there are two apps that I use so onx
is an app and I can pull it up and show
it to you now but it shows property
lines and and I've walked my own using
this and it's very accurate my officers
are using this for distances close to a
home we've entered it in a courtroom and
it's been accepted what's really neat
about it is it tells you pretty much
without exception who the landowner is
you immediately see the name you can
contact that person it shows you where
their home is where their outbuildings
are so it helps Hunters stay away from
those areas or from those sensitive
areas there's and you on X there's a fee
for that you can download it on your
phone I think I pay 31 a year for each
app uh Hunt stand is another free app
that I have on my phone I I from a
question from one of the other hearings
I want to make sure yeah Hunt stand is
free you can go to the go to a App Store
I can't but you get folks that know how
to do this can and you can purchase this
app and it'll do the same thing so it's
pretty accurate because it is an issue I
would encourage and have encouraged
people who have called us who couldn't
find a landowner we have a lot of
resources and I'll help you do that
because the goal is to make everybody as
happy as to give access to them and and
to if you can't find a landowner we can
help you do that so
um it's not impossible to do certainly
we purposely excluded
um and I think this is important
municipally on land publicly owned land
land owned or managed by the state of
New Hampshire we excluded permission
being required for any of those tracks
so it's solely for private land
municipally owned land was Town land I I
argued that is not private land that
would be excluded anyway but we wrote it
in just to be clear so anything owned by
the public we felt Hunters should be
okay to go on that so we excluded that
it's just the private landowner that
that we wanted them to ask permission
another very good question was how do we
make the case
on 24 hours so and how that came about
was the as technology advances we have
automatic rifles now that can be fired
without folks holding them that are
coming out we have cameras that film
live we have
um you know that the technology is ever
expanding and so we were concerned as an
agency about Hunter ethics we were
concerned about losing Fair Chase
principles getting away from that that's
an argument that's used to end the sport
of hunting fishing and trapping and and
we engage in those arguments on a
regular basis so I felt it was important
for us as an agency to get ahead of that
and so we said you know what those
aren't fair to be able to sit in your
living room and watch a deer go to a
tree stand and throw on your coat and go
out back and shoot a deer and everybody
I talked to says well you can't do that
well I'm here to tell you you would be
mistaken it can be done and it's done
pretty regularly with great success
quite frankly and so we we came up with
administrative rule a number of years
ago that said and still exists today
that says that you can't Harvest a deer
within 24 hours of it being viewed on a
camera and we quite honestly I helped
write that and I had no idea that I
would ever be able to enforce that law
because how would you do that and I'm
here to tell you we do it often and and
I'm surprised by that but the reason
that we do it is because the honesty of
the people that we encounter which is
refreshing you go to 100 and you say did
you see that on a camera and some of
these folks will admit to that which is
nice
um other times you can get a search
warrant and pull a camera as the
chairman spoke about and in his date and
time stamped on the camera even now uh
the these young kids that we've hired
can get it if you've deleted it so it
can be found uh frankly I'm not that
worried we're not that worried about
hunters we've had setups where people
had wired cameras sitting in their
living room really bad poaching uh
circumstance they're rare but that we've
had a number of those where we've made
those cases so those cases are made but
the message here I think is more
important a message that it says when we
when we put that in this law is that we
believe in Hunter ethics we believe in
Fair Chase principles and here it is in
the law for everyone to see so I think
that's an important piece the next very
good question was does a landowner have
to call us to go get it and my answer to
that would be even though it's in this
law I would never charge a landowner for
removing something on his own property
but but I've had many issues with that a
most recent one I had a young woman
remove a camera that was pointed at her
house so and of course there's always
more of these stories than what you get
the first time but the story was I had a
camera pointed at my house which I
thought was alarming and she said and so
I cut the cable and I removed it now the
police department's calling me and
telling me that I owe them a camera and
that I have to pay for the damage I did
to the cable so I called the police
department expecting to hear more and I
was not let down it was a lot more she
had been removed from her home wasn't
supposed to be back there they'd put a
camera on to make sure that she wasn't
coming back and they caught her doing
that the bottom line was though that was
the property of the town
and she destroyed it removing the camera
because most these cameras are locked on
so you're going to be forced to cut the
cable or cut the lock and I can tell you
from experience you'll put me in a
position where a camera owner will say
well that's good that that Mr Roy
removed my camera but he destroyed my
lock when he did it and he needs to pay
me for the lock and you know what he's
correct you do and so I wanted to a
landowner to avoid that I didn't want to
put a Lander on in that position so we
put in here that you should call
the other important piece of this law
was the fact that we asked for the name
and contact information to be put on the
camera giving a landowner an opportunity
to not get the police involved he could
just call Mr Roy and say remove your
camera I don't want it on my property
and give him a chance to work it out so
it was a we tried very hard throughout
this bill to balance all of that and to
give everyone something that we could
all work with so that's that's basically
how this all came about and lastly the
fine amount so the fine originally I
think when it was in the Senate I
followed chapter 6 25 under the criminal
code which denotes the limits for
violations limits for misdemeanors and
it says in a violation if you have a
violation of law you can charge up to a
thousand dollars in fines I don't know
of any violation today that would bring
a thousand dollars in any courtroom but
that's the limit that the law used so we
use that verbiage we scared the Senate
because I think they thought we were
going to charge a thousand dollars every
time we found one of these cameras and
so they reduced that to the 125 I don't
I don't really care what the fine is to
be honest with you I don't have a
personal preference on that there needs
to be a consequence so that people will
not do it if the law tells you not to do
it there needs to be a consequence so I
would entertain anything that you wanted
to put in there for a fine amount but
that's that's historically that's why
we're at the place that we are I'd
really encourage you to think about this
I know that Hunters I know that you've
gotten emails from Hunters I I this
gentleman from Conway brings up some
some valid points but I think we we
worked really hard to address those
we're allowing the cameras we're just
asking you to have the courtesy to ask
the landowner if he's okay with it
that's all and I don't think that's a
big reach thank you sir very much
um thank you colonel from a criminal
justice point of view
would it not be a problem for you to
make a case if the landowners were out
there taking these cameras down when you
get there the evidence is gone that the
violation never occurred is that not it
could affect it yes so you could I never
thought you could get into a chain of
custody issue so if you had a camera on
a bait site and there was no permission
for the bait to be there either which
happens and he took the camera and then
I looked to get the camera back from him
and download that evidence later I would
have a problem in a courtroom with a
good defense attorney saying well how do
you know he didn't put that picture on
him how do you know he didn't so that's
a very good point furthermore that that
it was ever placed without permission
correct that's correct okay thank you
thank you any questions for the colonel
yeah representative
I have two by my first one yes and we
talked about you can't
take the deer if you saw it on the
camera that day yeah what if I start on
the day before but it came back the day
I went out
how do you know well you don't and so
some discretion has to be used in that
and I I gotta tell you I don't see them
I don't see those I see every summons
these guys issue I review everyone
um because I look for things like that
to make sure that we're doing what we're
supposed to be doing and I don't see
that happening when I see it happening
is on what it's used in conjunction with
poaching or illegal baiting because it
could happen you could have you could
have a camera see a picture of a deer
and and I'm not against them in this
regard people work hard they don't have
time to sit in their stands every day I
get that so if they get a camera and it
says okay there's a buck coming here
every night at four o'clock if I get in
the stand I have a likelihood of seeing
a deer that's what those cameras should
be used for so I saw that yesterday
today I'm beyond that time I want to sit
in my stand and without me knowing it
that deer came out at 10 o'clock and got
caught on my camera you're going to know
that in an interview you're gonna know
when you're dealing with folks
um and and so that's that's a gray area
but it doesn't happen often for us so
yeah good question
those cameras going to be in the auction
this Saturday I don't know you know to
be honest with you I have not brought
those cameras over there I we should
probably do that I've got a pile of them
all over the state and I should go and
you know that's another reason that I
think this exploded is because cameras
when they first came out were very
expensive there weren't many people and
we use them I put them up for litter
sites when we have a road that people
are going down and dumping mattresses we
put these cameras out to try and catch
people we've had great success with them
so they are a great tool but but what's
happened now is the cost of these has
greatly reduced so you can buy these
things for twenty dollars and I think
people are there we've got cameras on
cameras trying to I've got cameras
pointed at other cameras to figure out
who's hunting and you know it's just
gotten ridiculous and I just think there
has to be some a little slow down there
before we lose our opportunity to hunt
on land owned by these generous folks
behind us I agree with you
representative salic
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um I'm just I'm not a hunter I'm gonna
put that out there I'm not a hiker I get
lost if you put me between three trees
so please don't go yeah I'm a city girl
my kids won't let me in the Woods by
myself anymore
um I'm curious whether with the cameras
the way the system is now if a landowner
were to go out and see cameras on their
property and they happen to be traveling
with a backpack full of blankets and
keep tossing them over the cameras is
that like
I'm sort of trying to understand whose
rights are are so a landowner has every
right to do that I've suggested the
landowners rather than take it down if
you're concerned about
um
a camera pointed at a barn because
people don't like Farmers for instance
uh you have every right to go over and
put I suggested put a good piece of tape
over it or covering the camera and
calling us and we'll come and get it you
have every right to do that every right
if you destroy property or you start
seizing property of other people then
you're kind of in a in a tricky spot
okay thank you yes ma'am
okay representative I know
thank you Mr chairman and I just wanted
to ask I was thinking about kind of the
responsibilities that would fall on Fish
and Game and it sounds to me first of
all like uh the phone calls that you're
getting from landowners you're already
getting that this would just kind of
provide a a better process for it but
also I think on behalf of the hunters
let me just say not a hunter I own
literally a tenth of an acre but
um my question would be you know I would
think that in order to be fair and for
this to be um a reasonable expectation
of hunters that would need to there
would need to be a lot of Education
we're seeing a lot of organizations that
work with people yes
um you know that represent a lot of
people who would you know good question
I'm just wondering about you know how
you would go about educating the public
so that it is reasonable so we did that
a good example of how we that's a good
that's a very good question I should
have testified to that so um we because
the gentleman from Conway is a very good
example of that and and I don't mean to
pick on him but he's a very good example
because he came in kind of late so he's
trying to figure this out and most
hunters will be in that position and so
when you folks gave us the lead law for
fishing I don't know if you recall that
when lead was excluded from being used
for tackle for fishing it was almost two
years before we ever issued a summons on
that so we went around when you when you
caught people without illegal stuff we'd
explain to them why it was illegal you
can't purchase it you can't possess it
you can't use it we used it as an
opportunity to educate people I see us
doing that for a good deal at least a
year for cameras because it's going to
take time for people that work and can't
attend these hearings to understand so
we would educate them long before we
charge them you know the thing I
stressed in my office is very important
to me the goal of law enforcement is not
to punish people although there's
officers out there that believe that's
our goal it's not our goal is to change
that behavior so if you can change that
behavior by having a conversation with
somebody you succeeded you don't have to
write the ticket that's the judge's job
that's not my job so education is a is a
very important piece so we would plan if
this were to pass we would put it on our
website we would do public notification
for it and we would be on an educational
campaign for a year and some of the
younger guys get frustrated with that
but it's important I think and then when
you when you start charging people there
is no reason at that point a year later
that they don't they shouldn't know that
this is the law it's been well
publicized so very good question
and and you produce a pamphlet you hand
out every year when everybody renews
their license there in the front of the
book will put changes to the laws this
year and we'll put this thing front and
center and we'd get a lot of call I'm
getting a lot of calls on it now from
both landowners and Camera people
because they want to know where we're at
with it
all the good point Rob the effective
date we move the effective date out on
this bill if you look I think it went uh
it's not even going to be in effect this
fall for that reason to start the
educational but thank you rob to start
the educational piece and that's good
because yes bow season starts in two
months three months it's too soon we've
got people already out there so it'll
give them a chance to do something
different
representative Newman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question yes sir
um since we primarily look at a
violation a violation would occur when
someone takes a camera and puts it on
somebody's land and it's not labeled
number one correct and they don't have
permission number two they would have to
meet both of those that's correct
situations and then that would be a
violation yeah yeah and in those
scenarios you know we don't always issue
both violation judicial warning for I
would anticipate a warning for one and a
violation ticket for the other
until we get people but yes that would
be two separate violations
so
I'm going to attract my follow-up I'll
I have a question in representative
Murray yes I'm thinking about how I'm
going to label my tree stands and I'm
picturing a three by five card laminated
with a zip tie somewhere up on the stand
yep
would there
would it be worth looking at a potential
for someone tampering with taking that
off it would be and so you know if
anyone were to ask me I would tell them
to try and engrave it or scratch it on
there somewhere and I wouldn't even mind
if it were you know in a position where
it's not readily seen because I got to
tell you me labeling my stuff I'm not
real anxious to put my name on a tree
stand I've got a few people out there
they're not real fond of me and so I
could see it giving providing an
opportunity police officers have already
reached out to me and said I don't
really want to put my name on that I
said well if we're going to make
everybody else do it fellows we got to
do it but I but I get that so I don't
know that that would be and I and I
think we would take that with a you know
if I were to find a stand like that and
and we may we require them to label bait
sites now with a three by five card and
typically a hunter will go in and remove
it we know that so you go in and you you
see the stand and you say to the guy hey
you don't have your sign up and he tells
you well I had it up I had it on that
tree and somebody removed it you tell
them put it back up and so it's not it's
not a huge deal it's just I would
engrave it if I were you and the other
reason I would do that if someone stole
it it gives us a way to get it back
which is helpful too I think
hmm
representative Murray and then represent
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
Cardinal for taking my question that
actually was uh related to that because
you know I'm concerned about the Privacy
rights of the hunters as well we were
too um and you know I got a lot of
emails from folks being concerned about
you know putting their name and contact
information where you know anyone can
get it including like you know maybe
Peta activist or whatever our
anti-hunting and then doxing these
Hunters I guess um how seriously do you
think those concerns should be so
originally when I wrote the Bill I put
name and address and I rethought that
for that reason so we put name and
that's why it says contact you know a
name and a cell phone or something
um but that's a concern I've had many
Hunters say the only thing I would say
to that is we already require names on a
number of different things we require
names and addresses on traps
um which certainly attracts those types
of people
um we require names on Bob houses
fishing Bob houses bait sites so there's
a number of things out there already and
we've not had knock on wood we've not
had real issues with that so we don't
feel that there will be an issue with
this
um we have and we also have
we also thank you we also have
um Good Hunter harassment laws to
address that so if someone were to do
that I would be all over that because
you yeah that escalates very rapidly uh
representative Lynn
yeah uh thank you Colonel for taking
this question um you know I know you
said uh earlier that you would never do
this but I'm I'm concerned that the way
the law this section 4 is written in
other words as I understand this and I
generally this seems like a really great
bill and I you know I very much support
but the one in general this bill it
seems to me draws an appropriate balance
between uh Hunters as an example and and
landowners and his and protects
landowners the one thing that seems to
be an exception to that is this section
four which see which it says
a property owner's shell not may but
shell
contact the department the fish and game
department to have to have a you know a
camera removed and so
am I wrong that that seems to me that
that is actually something that changes
the law
from what it is now to take away a
landowner's right in other words right
now if I read this
a landowner cannot
after If This Were if section four were
enacted a landowner could not even if
they had presumably even if they had
posted their land no hunting right a
landowner and landowner goes out walking
on their on their posted land sees a
camera they could not just take it down
they would have to call you right and
that seems to me I just wonder if that
is sort of an unintended consequence
that we've we've in that one respect
you've you've made it you've taken away
some rights from landowners that they
currently have yep and I guess as I read
it I mean if only if we were to enact
this section four and a landowner to
would were to do what I just said the
landowner would have would be subject to
the penalty because they would have
violated the statute it could be yes I
think more importantly though if they
remove it they've subject themselves to
civil penalties for the damages to
remove it so that's the issue that we've
had is when they when a landowner if I
felt if we didn't put something in there
to tell landowners not to do it the
landowners would in fact do it and
you're going to get into a we've already
had we've been the referee in several of
these where you have a hunter who wants
his equipment back and a landowner who
says well you're not getting it back
because you put it on my property
illegally well you can't do that by law
you're now you're now seizing equipment
that you don't own the law the law uses
this same type thought process when it
comes to abandoned vehicles or abandoned
property that's why our laws now
criminal laws prevent a landowner for
instance from seizing a car left on his
property there's a whole bunch of steps
they have to go through before they can
do that for these same reasons is you
you are exposing a landowner it's really
a protection for the landowner because
you're exposing them to all kinds of
civil penalties or violations of law if
they seize the camera because then it
becomes kind of a kind of a neighborhood
dispute between the hunter the Sportsman
and landowner because landowners don't
want to give them back my experience has
been they want to seize it they want to
meet the land the Hunter and they want
to lecture him and and it never goes
well and so we have found that it's
better to intervene early in that than
wait for that kind of scenario to go on
the landowner still has the right he has
the immediate right to call at any time
all we're saying is rather than you go
out and expose yourself to these
liabilities call us and we'll do it most
landowner do that now anyway
um you know and and there I have been
asked by the Farm Bureau about that very
issue we discussed that when we wrote
this bill early on and I I laid out kind
of the issues with allowing people to do
that the problems that we've had doing
that and we decided just I I want to
protect the landowner from that kind of
liability
I don't know what I can tell you I would
never allow a summons to be written for
a landowner doing something on his own
property that just wouldn't happen but
the LA I think the language needs to be
strong so that we don't have landowners
out there climbing tree stands and
seizing this stuff without without the
the authority of the law enforcement
Community being behind that yeah guys
just want to fight you know I guess the
thing that I'm not
I think you need to draw a distinction
don't you between it's one thing it
would seem to me
for the landowner to that sees uh you
know a camera or a tree stand in the
situation we're positive right to go
take it down
uh that's one thing I would it would
seem to me the landowner would have the
right to do that now if you're talking
about and I think this is what you're
talking if the if you're talking about
the landowner seizing it in the sense of
it's now become my property and I don't
have to give it back right there that's
a different issue isn't it it could be
you could separate those too but you
still run the risk of most of this stuff
that's put up there and I can tell you
from experience of seizing a lot of it
is locked down or cabled down or or the
cables are in and they don't know how to
function and so when you remove it you
end up destroying sometimes the property
to do it and the minute a landowner does
that he's now exposed himself to
replacement of that property and I can
tell you that's been a problem
um and so I and landowners don't think
about that until I tell them that and
they're surprised by that but I said
well that's a private property even
though it's there illegally it's owned
by this individual and and you he has
the right to be whole and you have to
put that you have to put that stuff back
that you've destroyed and so it kind of
exposes a landowner to a liability I
didn't really want to the other issue I
have the other real concern I have is
being caught doing it I can tell you in
a uniform I've been caught doing it and
and hunters get pretty aggressive about
that because that's their property and I
worry if a hunter were to find a
landowner removing that property we'd
we'd expose them to you know you've got
armed individuals I just worry about
that whole confrontation piece so we
kind of put that in here to avoid that
that was our goal
represent through did you have a
question
okay any further questions that scares
me representative I
don't I hope we you decided the right
thing
um
oh okay yeah no all good they're very
good questions and and we did it I kind
of insisted on that piece of it just
based on my experience with landowners
and and Property Owners I worry about
putting them in that and the law if you
think about criminal law has addressed
that at many different levels for the
same reasons uh they make you post
abandoned cars there's all kinds of
things you have to go through before you
can seize a car that's left on your
property which shouldn't be that way but
it has to be
go ahead uh my my thing was instead of
their whole name and address yeah their
first name and a telephone number that I
would that would be fine if they put
their name it doesn't say last name or
first name if it says name and contact
scitec Mr chair I hope the colonel has a
good succession plan
I I have some great people I'm very
fortunate that's why I hang on they they
uh I gotta get out of the way here very
soon but that's I have good people thank
you sir
seeing no further questions thank you
for your testimony unless um
Representatives giving you something
important reason
I'm all set okay thank you for your
I'd like to try to I wanted to hear what
the colonel had to say because I wanted
to come at this from a slightly
different perspective than what's been
presented today we've heard a lot about
uh feelings Traditions technology and so
forth
and from my perspective and people that
I know who want hunting
and want to manage Timber and Wildlife
you know for everybody to be able to
enjoy
not doing this creates conflict
this bill creates a better climate of
concert of cooperation
and
getting away from the feelings the
traditions and Technology I would like
to look I'd like to ask everybody on
this committee
to look to something that maybe they
have not looked at recently the first
section of the New Hampshire
Constitution
our New Hampshire Constitution is unique
it's much stronger than the Federal
Constitution relative to a number of
things
everything from property rights
it's a choice of gender and race and
everything else we've changed it twice
within my lifetime that I'm aware of
so it can be changed we want it to be
but the two pillars
of our constitution
comes down to privacy and property
rights
and to speak to both representative
newells
uh point about tenth of an acre
it's her property does it matter if it's
a tenth of an acre or 100 Acre it
doesn't matter
to speak to
the property issue related to trees
that's property under New Hampshire law
it's a crop under common law it's a crop
we have the right to harvest
a lot of folks in The Hunting Community
don't realize
when they put a tree I had
officer Chris McEwen a number of years
ago come on to my tree farm and remove
a property that I've managed since I was
14.
remove a tree tree stand from a veneer
to representative selig's question about
property damage oh I'm afraid she's not
here at the moment
uh it seems to me to be turned on its
head to speak maybe to Mr Rhodes Point
wherever the Rhodes Point seems to me to
be turned on its head
that the owner of the land
is now going to be held liable for
damage to property that somebody has not
simply abandoned like a car but
literally going on to the property and
strapped with a cable to a tree
that is a relatively
that's a pretty strong indication of a
permanent desire to have that
that sounds more like trespass
to me and to a lot of folks who come
across the situation
for all kinds of I mean
to not have the courtesy to be able to
call as a landowner to call somebody who
put a piece of property read a tree
stand or camera
to not be able to do that and to call
them and say hey look you know
not against cameras we could put this on
a different place uh or whatever I mean
that's what should happen you should not
have and I think it speaks to a
situation you should not have a somebody
like the colonel indicating that they
remove these things all the time and
they actually call you know they take a
picture in front of them with a card
held up
and yet from what he said nobody comes
the fact that we're even discussing this
to this level is really really
disturbing I mean I look to my ancestors
for a lot of guidance because they dealt
with stuff a lot tougher than we are and
Technology changes to representative
Boyden I believe who mentioned question
about
audio
does it really matter
doesn't matter whether it's a picture or
audio or a drone or a camera strap to a
tree technology is changing all the time
go back and read our constitution
the one thing about we can disagree
about 10 or 15 or 20 percent of it
amongst ourselves that's fine
but there's one thing about the
Constitution's the state constitution in
particular
it does not allow us to be schizophrenic
it really doesn't unless you want to
change the Constitution it is what it is
and it was respectful of people and
their various forms of property
and we need to think about that
and we need to think about the diffusion
of our resources and the actual cost
Associated when we have fish and game
going hither and yawn dealing with
things that are so easily solved
I fully support
hunting I have many people who want to
my property friends and neighbors they
are very possessive of the property
in a manner of speaking from a safety
I fully support this bill
to require the simple courtesy
of a name
or number or whatever is determined to
be right on a piece of private property
that is transported to another person's
property and strapped onto a tree or
something else
it's an observation device it's a form
of trespass it should not be tolerated
look to the Constitution and get rid of
an area of conflict
I wouldn't mind being challenged on some
of these things I've thought them
through a lot and I know you folks put
in a lot of time
I wouldn't challenge you but I would
point out that the constitution is to
restrict the government and not fellow
citizens so I'm sorry I couldn't hear
that would you say that again the
Constitution
um is to restrict the government not
fellow citizens having said that I agree
with your points the Constitution
affirms my perspective Constitution
affirms the rights that we have as
Citizens those rights in the
Constitution both federal and state
says that we essentially loan those
for the purpose of forming a more
perfect Society in essence
correct I think I would love to have a
legal debate with you over a cup of
coffee but I have to get this so
understood but I'm going to put it to
the rest of the members then whatever
your opinion is
respectfully
the government should not be
getting in the middle
of
issues that affect private property when
there's a better way to handle this
to make a property owner a landowner
liable for damage to a piece of
equipment that is being removed by a
officer of the law in any shape or form
that's been permanently attached
essentially at least for more than a
season usually
that's not the place
the way I understood it the peace
officer takes it
the landowner is not responsible that's
why the officer is coming to take it and
not to land on it and is that correct
Kyle
good
I simply think it's a very sad situation
when we're placing landowners in
conflict with people that we actually
want to support their rights we want to
well excuse me privileges of hunting on
land and so forth you are going to be
causing if this is not passed in a
decent form
you are going to be causing the mass
posting of many pieces of property
across the state that I do not like
and I and I I think we need to I've said
enough but there are no more questions
thank you very much thank you doesn't
matter tenth of an acre or 100 it's
still your own land thank you for your
testimony
as anyone else who has not filled out
the card who wishes to test spawn this
bill today
seeing none I hereby close the public
hearing on SB 14 and we are going to
take a 10 minute break and we will open
the public hearing SB 15 just for
everyone's um edification will be
exacting this probably about 15 to 20
minutes after we close that hearing so
hopefully we'll be moving much more
expeditiously because if you testified
on 14 there's no need to tell us the
foreign
at this point we're going to open the
public hearing on SB 15.
okay and
daily daily for that to introduce the
good afternoon chairman Roy members of
the committee my name is Daley frenette
and I'm the Senate majority caucus
director I am here this I'm here this
afternoon to introduce Senate Bill 15 on
behalf of Senator Pearl
Senate Bill 15 amends the permissible
uses of tree stands observation blinds
and pip lines as amended Senate Bill 15
clarifies the people who wish to erect
treestand observation blind or pip line
must have written permission from the
property owner it also requires that any
tree stand observation blind or pip line
be labeled by the with the owner's name
and contact information
the bill also designates that they may
be erected on property between August
1st and December 31st of the calendar
year and must be removed by the end of
this time period unless permission is
given by that property owner
Property Owners may call local or state
law enforcement or a conservation
officer to remove and seize a permanent
portable or temporary tree stand or
observation line which was placed or the
owner of which has failed to remove that
that equipment
Sarah Pearl hopes that by giving
Landover Landover is more say in what
goes on on our property it will
incentivize them to keep their land open
for New Hampshire Hunters thank you for
allowing me the opportunity to speak
this morning if you have any questions
I'd be happy to bring them back to
Senator Pearl for you
no thanks we actually like instant
responses to our questions so
thank you
um and relay our thanks to Senator Pearl
um at this point the chair recognizes
um well actually before I call any
Witnesses if you've already testified
and you're going to testify again please
just limit it to the tree stands because
we we pretty much understand I think the
concept that everyone's trying to
impress upon us on the private private
private property and and for the most
part I think we are all in agreement so
at this point I would call Susan price
foreign
thank you Mr chair
um I'm Susan price Fish and Game
connection commissioner for Carroll
County
um it's really just a replay of my prior
testimony
um the only difference is this actually
is a hunting bill this is very specific
very
tree stands are used primarily by
hunters
but all the other issues really stand
and the commission is dedicated
to increasing and maintaining public
access wherever we can so we have full
support of this bill and much like the
prior one we worked very hard with the
stakeholders
to to make this a very workable bill and
we would very much appreciate your
support
thank you any new questions
representative yeah you know I just I
have a just a question I'm
it's this is really a sort of a language
question it says in paragraph four
except for permissions granted by
property owners
in paragraphs five and six and then it
goes on and it goes on to say that the
permittee has to carry the permit
um with him and and display it if asked
to do so uh by a conservation officer
and I guess my question is this so it
says except for permissions in paragraph
five and six five talks about permanent
tree stands or or or observation blinds
and six talks about temporary tree
stands or observation blinds so my
question is what if those two are
accepted from the requirement of having
a your permit with you what ones
are you required to have your permit
with you uh I think you're this is the
amended as amended by the house
uh I believe so the latest version is
the latest version yes
um I really can't speak to that um that
was not in the original Bill and um I
can't speak to the logic for that
language
um as it was amended
okay I mean so perhaps okay perhaps um
we'll we'll save that for the current
okay sure all right bye any further
questions
seeing none thank you
hello again I'll be incredibly brief
Wildlife Federation fully supports this
bill if you're placing a piece of
property you're something on somebody
else's property you should put your name
and contact information on it so
I'm gonna go relatively quickly through
these Witnesses so if you do have a
question please don't be shy and let me
know
um the chair recognizes Anna Mark Davis
again
thank you again I'm still Ann Davis I
still own 500 Acres next to the John F
Gile Memorial State Forest
we had an experience about four years
ago with a fellow who had a tree stand
right next to one of our Trails it was
not marked
uh and I put a note on the tree stands
please contact me we're not comfortable
having you have this tree stand here he
finally did call me back he said well
this is really good location because a
lot of game comes down this trail and I
said yes I realized that but I'm not
comfortable with it would you please
move it so my suggestion is and I
support this bill because it would give
a landowners and Hunters an opportunity
to sort this out before they were
already set up for the season
and we've had a good relationship since
then even though he was a little
reluctant to to move the tree stand so
uh the other component is uh he did put
the stand it was a temporary stand it
didn't have any uh damage to the tree
that he used
but I just think it would be prudent to
give us all a chance to have a another
conversation and a contact with the
hunting community and I think that would
help facilitate this thank you for the
opportunity and thank you for your
service on our behalf to the state
and thank you for sharing with us
I'm assuming
yeah no one spoke up so nope
thank you uh just briefly I want to
thank the committee for allowing us to
come down and speak uh
both my wife and I support Senate Bill
15 also is written and I would just like
to uh emphasize one thing about the
relationship that we as landowners have
had over the years with the New
Hampshire fishing game and in particular
with the colonel
Jordan and other members of his staff
have been incredibly helpful to us in
various things from hunting fishing and
vandalism and we thank them for the
service that they provide thank you all
Walter Lacy
foreign
thanks I think I pretty much covered
you said this is the culmination of a
frustration of a number of years and my
my issue has been in the past is I'd
come across a stand is it abandoned and
I left
flagging with my name another never
occurred from these people and so that's
been frustrating just to to establish a
dialogue and the other thing is it's
frustrating to have trees damaged so I
think it's a simple resolution put your
name on it and get permission thanks
Jason stock with the New Hampshire
Timberland Owners Association we support
the bill we think it's for all the
reasons you just heard and I'd be happy
to answer any questions
real quick just for the committee could
you tell us the potential damage or or
monetary value of a uh we heard a
testimony before of a near-grade piece
of Timber how much could that cost the
landowner by somebody putting screws
into it or strapping it too tight
yeah I mean it a veneer grade log is I
mean you can be talking hundreds of
dollars if it's a veneer a single log a
single veneer grade log
this bill deals with portable tree
stands as opposed to permanent where
you're putting screws in that you know
that's already covered in law but even
with a portable if you leave a stand on
um
you know and if there's a chain the tree
will actually grow around it and of
course that log is no longer useful so
even Portables if they're left up for
extended periods of time can damage
trees
so yeah you're talking hundreds of
thank you any further questions
I'd like to Echo Jason's testimony and
and give you a couple of quick examples
uh I support both this bill and the last
bill as well obviously uh I was the one
to mention the veneer grade Oak that was
a situation where Chris McKee again that
officer he had to go
running around uh there's a number of
Oaks back there where people have been
putting stands up and he had to go
running up and down the street knocking
on doors to try to figure out who it was
uh because of it was just off a property
where there's a development that's a
waste of their time if there had been a
name on there we could have easily just
called them
second situation was one where the
person does put there I mean we have
some good people in our area they put
their name and number on the tree stand
knew who it was gave him a ring it gave
me a chance to educate them about the
value of the Timber
that they didn't know about they didn't
know they'd stuck it on a high-grade
sugar maple and
we have a great relationship that was 10
or 12 years ago
and they hunt my property now
again like I said in the first bill this
is cooperation this is about respective
private property
so please pass this bill unchanged
and just move on
the chair calls um
Kevin Jordan again a chief of law
enforcement New Hampshire fishing game
and thanks again for entertaining us and
I'm sorry for all the trouble
um
uh another really good question I wish
you to stay at home today quite frankly
um so I'm going to try to explain what
how that came about so the original Law
20736a I believe it is for tree stands
requires today if you would have put up
a permanent tree stand a permanent tree
stand is any tree stand that does damage
to property or could potentially do that
or anything that you insert into a tree
so screwed in steps cutting tree
branches so I have a clear shot with a
bow
um I built one where you're nailing it
to the tree any of those types of stands
require written landowner permission and
you have to have that permission with
you that was created a number of years
ago and we enforced that today if you
hunt and stands like I use which are
climbers
um and if you're not familiar with those
there are cables that go around a tree
they're portable you can you know very
light you can drag them in with you when
you're ready to hunt and you climb the
tree using the stand it doesn't do any
damage other than scratching the bark
going up but doesn't insert anything
into the tree and you'd remove it at the
end of the day there's no requirement
for written landowner permission for
that we still encourage Hunters to go to
the landowner and ask that you know
permission to do it but there's not a
requirement for a permit
so then again going back to my original
with the camera the same similar calls
from landowners every fall they don't
know who these people are these stands
are up they didn't ask on permission so
we were trying to address both these
issues last year we tried to address it
it kind of got it went sideways because
the two bills were attached together
they were amended multiple times and it
became a real mess and the house finally
said and I think correctly we can't pass
this so this year I separated those two
so I wrote a camera Bill and then I
wrote a tree stand bill so the tree
stand bill in an effort to balance as
I've said before the rights of a
landowner and and the ability for sports
men and women to hunt
we put in some caveats in this which
ended up I think making a little bit
confusing so
um the goal here is to allow the use of
stands just like we always did not
change the permanent stands so a
landowner still has to give permission
for that and we went a step further in
saying that if you one other problem
that I get or call that I get from
landowners is z stands go in and they
stay up permanently and the reason they
stay up permanently is because Hunters
have a good spot and they don't want
someone else to move in there so they
leave their stands up frankly they'll
give you 100 excuses but the fact of the
matter is they'll leave their stand up
because they want me when I come in as a
hunter to see if there's already a tree
stand there and go somewhere else and so
they end up leaving these stands up
claiming their property claiming their
their special spot a lot of landowners
don't like that obviously so I didn't
want to take that away from a hunter if
they wanted to do it and the landowner
doesn't care I hunt on property the
landowner doesn't care if I leave it up
he says you can leave it up all year for
all I care as long as you're not hurting
my property so we wrote this bill to
allow for both so what we said was you
have to you you can only put them in in
that time frame between August 31st and
December 31st of each calendar year
unless and it has to be removed I put
January 1st every year it got amended in
the house to April 1st and I I it
escapes me why that happened but I'm
okay with that
um unless you get permission from the
landowner it says I don't care and then
you can leave it up so it gives both the
Sportsman in my opinion it gives the
Sportsman the right the ability to to do
just what they're doing today with
permission and it gives a landowner to
say no I don't want that I want it
removed it was I was trying to balance
both and so the paragraph that you're
asking about Sir is except for
permission granted by property owner in
paragraph five and six we didn't require
it this is where it's a little confusing
I didn't require it in writing
so a permanent tree stand you have to
get it in writing from the landowner
representative Roy would have to sign
his name saying it gives Kevin Jordan
permission to hunt we didn't ask for
written permission for all these other
things and I'll tell you why I didn't do
that is my experience as a hunter and as
a game warden landowners are very
hesitant to sign their name to something
that says I'm going to allow you to
climb a tree on my property even though
we have good liability laws on the books
and they've been tested in a case in
Deerfield recently where a landowner is
protected against liability if a hunter
gets hurt on their property there are a
number of landowners who will tell you
including the one I hunt on I'm not
signing anything I'll give you
permission but I'm not signing anything
and so I was concerned about that that
we'd put hunters in a position where a
landowner really didn't care that that
they were on their property but they
didn't want to sign it and so I said
just get permission and and you'll
notice the word written is excluded and
that's the reason for that so how this
would work I would encounter Hunter
Jason stock hunting on a piece of
property I would say to Jason
you have permission to have that tree
stand here yes I do I went to I went to
Rob Johnson the landowner and he gave me
permission to do that I can check on
that I can call Rob Johnson if I want to
do that and find out if he gave him
permission I don't need something in
writing if I required it to be in
writing Rob Johnson might tell him no
I'm not going to sign it and then he
can't hunt on it so that's kind of the
reason we did that so we're saying in
that paragraph except as required in
five and six which is that special
permission
you have to carry that written
permission from the former law that says
that you are okay to have a permanent
stand is that did I clear that up or did
I confuse you more
you confused me more that's the intent
of it if you if you have a better way to
write it I'm all he is but that's the
intent we we were trying to balance we
didn't want to change the prior law we
think it's a good law but we didn't want
to require landowners to sign something
they didn't want to sign or they were
they were leery of signing I've had many
conversational landowners saying if you
allow people on your land if you allow a
snow machine Trail ATV trailer or tree
stand and a sports man or woman get
injured you're not liable but we live in
a world where we all know
sometimes it costs money to prove that
you're innocent and and as long I'm
being sued I think I've got four
lawsuits pending on me currently it's
pretty common for anybody that does
anything in this business you get sued
and and I'm being sued in one case where
I followed the law to the letter and I'm
still being sued it costs money to prove
that you're innocent so I didn't want to
put a landowner in that position I
wanted I didn't want a hunter to not
have an opportunity to hunt a piece of
property because a landowner was
concerned about signing something so we
we wrote it in this fashion requires you
to get the permission but it's not in
writing that could be used against the
landowner later
the other
um
uh the Senate May amend this when it
goes back because they are concerned
about turkey stands in the spring which
I didn't give any thought to
so we may have to go back to that date
of January 1 for the removal to allow
people to put them up in the spring but
I'm going to let the Senate decide that
that isn't in this version so the the
the January 1
date change I did I may have some
responsibility I
um thank you very much sir I was
concerned uh about elderly Hunters being
out there in December in two feet of
snow right trying to get a metal street
I was worried about heart attacks
falling yep I said what's the problem
waiting another couple months till the
ground is safe yeah um so I would I
would concern I'd have similar concerns
about a turkey stand first of all I
didn't know people didn't just well so
at my point to the senator to Senator
Pearl is a friend of mine I said I don't
know how that it makes a difference on a
on a stand or blind for turkey but I
didn't want to interfere with that I
don't want to create a scenario where
you interfere with that so I was open
for that discussion and actually that
idea was presented to me by chairman
splane about the wintertime thing and we
conceded to allow the April
um I try to make it simple for Folk
because I my experience has been the
more simple you may get the less
violations you get so if you say they're
going to be out by December 31st or
January 1st people remember that they
can remember April 1st too so it doesn't
matter as long as it's clear I think and
remember they can get permission and
none of that applies they can they go to
landowner that doesn't care then all of
that is null and void it's just making
them go to the landowner is the goal
here
representative Newman just a quick
question so the the person that has that
if they want them off as a specific date
if they're going to give permission to
someone they could put any date that
they want they could put anything they
want it's their land yep if this is
absent a date or absent permission it
would have to be that way yes landowner
reserves that right to do whatever they
want I'm not sure it's this bill at a
previous bill it says that your
department is going to create a form
um for the permission I think it was
it's this one which we have already for
the permanent stand so we have one and
that form allows for any date to be put
it does okay yes yeah it's just
landowners are very I don't know if you
found that but landowners are very
nervous about signing their names and I
understand that yeah so we left this
provision in so they wouldn't have to if
they chose not to
um representative Lynn did you need some
further clarification on that or so I I
well I guess I I you know I don't want I
my my former job used to be to be a
nitpicker so that's why I'm knitting I
would have called you a judge I think a
judge so here's what I'm am I
understanding then
that you don't need to have
a permit that you carry with you
if you if you construct a permanent tree
stand with permission that doesn't have
to be per written permission
um
but that tree stand cannot damage the
tree because if it does if it is going
to damage the tree then you have to have
written permission that's correct okay
except you called it in the first part
of it a permanent so it really wouldn't
be a permanent one well but see that
that's where I have a problem because in
paragraph one it talks about uh
shall
um that's the original Law yep that's
the original Law and that talks about it
whether it damages a tree that's correct
and that's true for that you need
written permission that's correct and
you have to carry that on your purse
button paragraph five also talks about a
permanent tree stand and that doesn't
require written permission it does and
it and it doesn't describe the same
detail as the paragraph one up above
you're right so I that could have been
eliminated quite frankly I'm not sure
how that got put in there but that
particular line could have been
eliminated I think we're on the same
page you and I okay I think I think you
understand what I what we're trying to
do here but it would be helpful if that
first line that number five really
doesn't need to be there
I hate to see it go back to another
committee
because I worry every time this goes
before a committee but
yeah we could um we could if the
Senate's intending to work on it anyway
just let them do that I can ask Howard
the senator Pearl to do that yeah okay
yeah any further questions
seeing none thank you thank you very
much sir is there anyone here wishing to
testify in sb15 who did not submit a
card and wishes to do so
seeing none here I close the public
hearing on SB 15 and we are going to
and I will make a motion of
ought to pass
seconded by representative Harry
gathright
I'll speak to my motion I think we've
heard plenty of testimony today I'm a
Hunter I watch out for Hunter's rights
I'm part of the reason the bill failed
last year because somehow between all
the Committees and the two two different
bodies it in my opinion ended up to be a
mess this is much cleaner it protects
landowners protects Hunters I think it
does what it sets out to do
um so in the interest of keeping
land available for hunters to hunt
I suggest that we pass this bill would
you like to speak to your second
representative Catherine
I think it was well set and I truly
enjoyed all the testimony from the
homeowners land owners tonight today so
it was quite interesting thank you
discussion
representative Manion thank you Mr chair
uh just to address representative Lin's
concerns
um I understand that that being in the
law the penalty could apply to the
landowner I mean the property owned as
well but I think it's talking about
forfeiting the game camera uh and
fastening devices in the penalty section
kind of proves our intent that it's
towards the game camera person as
opposed to the property owner so that
Roman numeral four about them contacting
the law enforcement officer I don't
think the penalty would apply to that
I think that if you had a literalist
Justice it may
um if you had one that bothered to look
at the intent of the legislature that it
would not and are speaking about it
right now we are making our intent known
so
penalties of
these and it's almost like it's just a
license
fee as opposed to a real penalty
125 dollars
what's that
it's a um
I believe that they this was vetted um
pretty pretty hard by uh of numerous
different people on whether that was
enough it does go up to a thousand
dollars potentially for a violation and
I think that they came to the conclusion
that for a lot of people that hunt
they're not necessarily people of means
and 125 dollars
um I believe that they thought was
enough
whether or not it is or not
um I guess time will tell they would
forfeit their equipment which is
probably ends up being more than that in
the end
and I am curious to know what Colonel
Jordan is there other license
um as as we get older the the years we
have to hunt shrink and losing one of
them is very valuable
um representative Newell
yeah I would just add that one of the
things I really appreciate about this
bill and the way that it's written is
that and you know you know what I think
is reflected in a lot of the testimony
is that it's not meant to be
um a stick it's meant to be a carrot
it's meant to be something that is like
or not a care but it it's meant to be
something that is
um uh a nudge and say hey uh let's be
courteous to each other and things like
that not necessarily if you do this then
I'm not putting this properly but you
get my point so I'll be voting in favor
yeah it's um it's definitely educational
but it does have some teeth
any further comments representative
Murphy thank you Mr chair
um I'll be voting in support but I would
have liked to have seen a clause
um whereby property owners could have
removed
um the game cameras on their own with no
liability for damage to those cameras
um as those cameras are placed there
without the permission of the property
owners but you know in I don't want to
throw away the the perfect for the good
so absolutely I think it's a it's a um
obviously necessary and and um I'll be
supporting this
thank you I I just to respond to that I
I I struggled with that a little bit too
but at the end from the criminal justice
committee standpoint if a landowner
takes it down what they've done is
they've taken away the evidence of the
crime so if you call the the fish and
game to come out and say hey this person
violated this law they put this camera
up without permission okay take me to it
well it's in my garage well they can't
they can't prove the crime anymore so
and I really do take stock in what the
colonel said is avoiding confrontations
with armed hunters in the middle of the
woods some of them who are not
necessarily as nice as we would hope and
it can be very intimidating for I'd hate
to see a landowner get in that position
so I agree in my natural instinct says
my property I can do what I want but
unfortunately
for the purposes of proving the crime
and avoiding unnecessary tragedies I
think that it's best left that way but
you are free to Lobby to Senate
any further
seeing none I'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll
the motion on Floors ought to pass
representative Lynn
yeah breakfast representative Pratt yes
representative scitec yes yes
representative Pooh yes representative
janvrin yes representative mannion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenzar yes
representative kathry yes representative
Brennan yes representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes
the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
salic yes representative Schultz yes
chairman Roy chariables yes
uh 20-0 motion Bots pass carries by
unanimous 20-0 any objection to consent
seeing none the bill will go on the
consent calendar I hereby close the
executive session on sb14 I hereby open
the executive session on sb15 I make a
motion of ought to pass
seconded by representative gas right
again representative pru you're a little
slow on that one
I will speak to my motion everything I
said previously still applies if not
um it's not as onerous a tree stand
isn't as onerous as something capturing
pictures of you but nonetheless it is
your property it can damage your trees
and it can be disconcerting to walk
through your woods and see a structure
there and I do believe
that as well as continuing to allow
Hunters access to land it these these
permission things will Foster
conversations and relationships between
landowners and good hunters and that's
what we want is the good hunters and if
you're not a good Hunter and you're not
interested in talking landowners maybe
you ought to find another sport
would you like to speak to your second
representative Gathering I think it's
well said by you
discussion
represent salic well using one of these
stands allow me to find the marshmallow
peeps after the Easter season
I do I do believe it will but you do
to see no further discussion I would ask
the clerk to call the roll the motion on
the floor for sb15 is ought to pass
representative Lynn yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative Prue you betcha
representative Jan friend yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tensar yes representative
Harry Gathering yes representative
Brennan yes representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
salic yes representative Schultz yes
chairman Roy Tribbles yes motion is
unanimous 2-0 motion wants past carries
by unanimous vote any objection to
consent seeing none it will go into
consent calendar hereby close executive
session on SB 15. and we are finished
our business for today I'm not going to
say a darn thing about coming back here
again
um just watch your emails enjoy your